le port marly sera la ville où se
tiendra le 92ème congrès national de la
gm
l'association générale des enseignants
des écoles et classes maternelles
publiques
elle a été créée en 1921 elle a été
créée à vichy par un groupe
d'enseignants tu vois là dès qu'ils se
sont réunis parce qu'il y avait déjà une
inégalité de salaires
à cette époque et les collègues se sont
regroupés autour de cette association
pour faire la promotion de l'école
maternelle pour défendre les intérêts
des enseignants et défendre les intérêts
des enfants en comité restreint tous
réfléchissent à l'organisation du
congrès annuel pour promouvoir l'école
maternelle et en particulier la
thématique des arts c'est un véritable
moment où bat le coeur de la maternelle
et où les enseignants qui viennent là
c'est en même temps pour se ressourcer
pour partager et au sein de l'académie
de versailles
tous ceux qui ont travaillé depuis
depuis trois ans et offrir ce moment et
ses espaces pour se retrouver et parler
de la maternelle qui est nôtre
voilà notre passion il met au point
l'organisation des expositions
pédagogiques mais aussi toute la
logistique
pendant trois jours ils établissent le
programme précis des journées du congrès
un rendez vous très attendu pour les
enseignantes passionnant de pouvoir
rencontrer ce qui est fait par les
autres collègues échanger avec les
autres collègues sur ce qu'elles font
leurs pratiques de classe et cet échange
là est source de formation pour nos 1200
personnes sont attendues au congrès il
se déroulera du 3 au 5 juillet 2019 aux
pyramides à port marly